alors on y va
[Musique]
bah oui plus que jamais parce que là
j'ai pas de temps à perdre alors où le
capitaine il est sur le pont et droits
devant
[Musique]
non je l'écouté toujours avec le même
plaisir des jams qui n'est pas un jeune
artiste qui n'est plus là mais comme je
l'entends des jeunes comme malraux nîmes
en liaison m'échappe quelquefois par
exemple n'y a pas longtemps je parlais
de zaz c'était une merveille zaz et puis
il ya julien doré et puis il y a il
faudrait que je demande à ma compagne 6
1 où est mon seul hic j'adore ces mannes
slimane et évita assez formidable mais
il y en a d'autres
[Musique]
sûrement pas on n'est pas en compétition
du tout on est en activité l'un et
l'autre bien que lui c'est ce parce que
sa tournée never ending tour ça fait
plus de dix ans qui n'arrête pas on
n'est pas du tout en compétition mais
disons que dans les mois ou dans les
années à venir
ça serait bien s'ils le pouvaient le
retrouver encore non franchement non
c'est en 2016 lui les gens de peu sont
venus me trouver
comme il était très sympathique calcul
thivet étrelles bien élevé il voulait
pas rencontrer alors je les ai invités à
prendre le café à la maison on a discuté
et il voulait que je me présente et donc
le leur demander
politiquement vous vous situez comment
la vie ce point si l extrême gauche en
réalité quelqu'un m'a dit après non il
était à l'extrême droite mais il ya des
ajustements des braves gens là dedans
les bonnes intentions mais il ya aussi
le développement si j'ai pas envie 2
c'est pas politique mais par contre je
vous dire aujourd'hui j'ai décidé
j'ai toujours refusé le terme de
chanteur engagé qui me fait bien rigoler
parce que empêcher le par qui par quoi
et le recueillement
mais aujourd'hui j'ai envie maintenant
j'ai passé le cap horn de lavie 4e 10
ans j'ai envie de m'engager pour essayer
de participer à la la renaissance d'un
mouvement chrétien pour ne pas que notre
culture chrétienne disparaissent
je me dis bien la culture chrétienne les
églises cependant avec les églises de
villiers hôtels ou des roues des boîtes
de nuit comme ça donc je suis un peu
avec eux stéphane bern pour essayer
d'éviter cette chose à nous à né pas
croire que ce soit totalement religieux
c'est que je crois
humainement culturel
[Musique]